hey youtubers is Charlie so Marvel just
dropped some concept art from guardians
of the galaxy to it was part of a scene
that appeared in the comic-con trailer
so I'm just gonna do a breakdown explain
what's going on
giant tentacle Lovecraft nightmare so
this is basically the beast that was
described in the comic-con trailer so
Elizabeth - Becky plays something of an
antagonist in the film but she doesn't
start out that way
she's like the leader of this
genetically perfect people they're kind
of like a bunch of so like
imagine when the Star Trek Enterprise
would go to like a different planet and
they'd have this really weird culture
and there'd be all this awkward comedy
around the Enterprise crew making
inappropriate comments so like Rocket
Raccoon just makes all these
inappropriate jokes and it's just really
funny but Elizabeth - Becky's character
hires the guardians to take care of this
space monster that is threatening their
civilization and as you'd expect nothing
goes according to plan so as they take
on the mission everything ends up going
sideways and that becomes a big part of
the a story but like you look at this
here you see a better picture of dancing
baby Groot who doesn't have a uniform on
James Gunn said that like the Ravagers
put like a tiny little Ravagers uniform
on him and he just gets super pissed off
imagine like a tiny pissed-off version
of Groot the monster itself obviously
it's not gonna look like this in the
film this is just concept art things
always change quite a bit between the
concept phase and like the actual stuff
that ends up on screen so it doesn't
look too Lovecraftian I don't know if
this is something straight out of the
comics but there have been a number of
really weird space monsters that the
guardians have run into in the comics so
you could say that this is inspired by
the comics but but obviously they I
think they made it like a little less
frightening looking like it's kind of
Lovecraftian it even looks a little bit
like the shuma gorath from the Doctor
Strange comics but that's not what it is
it kind of looks like a less nightmare
fuel version of the many angled ones
which is something from the cancerverse
in the realm of Kings storyline in the
comics if you never read realm of kings
it's kind of an Inhumans storyline I
know everybody wonders if they're gonna
do Inhumans in the movies but this looks
like they're just borrowing that it gets
tied up with a big universal Church of
truth storyline they worship this big
beast and bring it into our reality and
it becomes a big part of that storyline
so maybe that means we'll see some
Universal Church of true stuff in
Dean's volume to that may actually be
pretty cool but just to explain Shuma
gorath the shoe mcgrath is like the
demon lord of chaos so like if the shoe
Magoo earth was threatening your
civilization there was probably nothing
you could do to stop it if you didn't
have an infinity gem so this is more on
the level of star wars trash compactor
monster like a big threat but not
something that's completely
insurmountable but it's gonna cause all
kinds of really fun chaos in the film
isn't it crazy though giant tentacle
monster and guardians of the galaxy in
giant tentacle monster in Doctor Strange
it's like James Gunn and Scott
Derrickson the directors of these two
films decided that phase 3 needs more
cowbell always more cowbell in giant
tentacle monsters are the cowbell of the
Marvel Universe
so tentacle jokes aside but I don't know
if I mentioned it but there's this big
idea with like things being the only
thing of its kind in the galaxy like
Rocket Raccoon is the only thing of its
kind Peter Quill's father ego the Living
Planet one of the only things of his
kind - so the ideas of loneliness
searching for a family like the links
you go to the things you do to create a
family for yourself or a big theme in
the film like why would a Living Planet
make himself a human body and tried to
have a child with a human woman James
Gunn is implied that just because he was
so lonely so that's gonna be a big theme
in the film but you know being the only
one of your kind building families
loneliness with liberal sequel jokes I
imagine there's gonna be a lot of Empire
Strikes Back jokes but I know a lot of
you were wondering there's you know so
much cosmic stuff happening in guarding
this galaxy I think I've already
mentioned James Gunn said no Thanos no
infinity gem this doesn't really
directly connect to the other Avengers
films but we might see some sort of
post-credit scene where it links up with
Thor because Thor the dark world did
have that post-credit scene where they
took the power gem to the collector and
thor ragnarok is the next Marvel film
after guardians of the galaxy vol 2 so
it makes sense that there's some sort of
connective tissue between those two
movies but we haven't at any
confirmation of a post-credits scene or
anything official like that not on the
level of the Thor stuff that I just
posted like it looks like there's a
full-blown Doctor Strange Thor crossover
that's going to be teasing infinity war
stuff like Thor and Loki resolve their
differences during Thor Ragnarok
and Loki takes Thor to meet dr. strange
the sorcerer supreme so let me know in
the comments do you think that guardians
of the galaxy will have some sort of
Thor post-credit scene I feel like they
don't have to but I can't remember the
last Marvel film I saw that did not have
a post-credits scene with connective
tissue to one of the upcoming movies so
just expecting some sort of Thor end tag
at that movie but congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner Keith
Edwards you win a $20 Amazon gift card
just be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details so there'll be more
Marvel stuff happening later this week
I'm probably gonna do some more DC flash
tomorrow
they've been tweeting a bunch of stuff
about the episodes they're working on
and we're probably gonna get a couple
more trailers for the TV shows that are
coming back in October
pretty much every comic book TV show
Marvel and DC is coming back at the end
of September the beginning of October so
a whole bunch of stuff is gonna be
dropping in the next couple weeks there
like everybody is just gonna be dumping
their trailer so it's gonna be fun to
see what some of this new stuff that's
coming looks like agents of shield is a
good example I'm not gonna talk about it
too much just because this is a
guardians of the galaxy video but
there'll be more agents of shield stuff
coming soon while you guys wait for my
next video you can click here to learn
all about the Thor Doctor Strange
crossover that's gonna be happening at
Thor Ragnarok blow your mind and you can
click here to learn all about spider-man
homecoming and the comic book characters
they're doing thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight